on a small island in northeast Japan the
people are outnumbered and ruled by
fickle little kings cats ruled by cats
tashirojima is home to twice as many
cats as people it has a cat shrine it
has multiple cat shaped buildings and
dogs are forbidden from coming on land
the cats are clearly in charge as they
are in any situation in which there are
cats of course Toshiro Juma is known by
another name Cat Island in the 1800's
tashirojima was home to soap producers
and fishermen and they had similar
problems one the fishermen's nets would
get chewed up by mice to the so
producers silkworms would get eaten by
mice the natural answer to this was to
import a bunch of cats and cats are also
associated with good luck and fortune so
for everyone it was a wonderful
symbiotic relationship there's something
more going on here because tashirojima
well the oldest and most well known is
not the only Cat Island in Japan there
are at least eleven here I'm going to
horribly mispronounce uh these islands
in Oshima okishima sanic sanic Ashima a
Oshima Mizuki's Jima
Iwo Jima I do ma Jinga Shima mana be
Shima mana be Shima
manemma Shima oh man so all of these
islands share the name Nikko Jima or Cat
Island recently when someone posted a
bunch of Twitter pics of cat surrounding
them a Oshima a tiny island with 17
permanent residents became
internationally famous overnight and
took on the title of Cat Island so all
of these islands share a few
characteristics they have basically cats
old people and not much else these
islands also make perfect environments
for cats they often don't have predators
on these islands many of these islands
don't have cars
the cats are looked after and cared for
by the mostly elderly resident in fact I
know Shima one of the residents is
referred to as the cat which I think
just by like Western media someone just
called her a cat which but got a cat
which I would an awesome thing to be
called and this
point it's practically an experiment in
cat per square meter density like at
some point we will hit the wall of
resources and they'll be like too many
cats that which leads to only one
possible thing catabolism so will - sure
Juma is loving all the cat focused
attention they have cat photography
contests and cat exhibitions not all the
islands feel so great about it
a Oshima the newest Cat Island is
overwhelmed by the tourists every day
twenty to thirty tourists are coming to
see the cats and there's nothing on the
island our restaurants there's nowhere
to go both a Oshima and tashirojima are
what's known as Geng Kai Sharaku
pronunciation apologies 50% of their
residents are 65 or older and this means
that they're going to populate
eventually and the neck edema will truly
be ruled by the cats subscribe here and
watch more videos here if you fight like
dogs and monkeys that's where you say
when people don't get along in Japan
they fight like dogs and monkeys do dogs
hate monkeys and we just don't know it I
would love to hear about what you think
the world's most amazing hidden wonders
are let us know in the comments or send
us an email or let us know on Twitter
find us and tell us
yeah